let's do a classic problem it really
shows up every time you take a flight I
have to calculate something like this
very recently because I have a flight
from San Francisco to New York so it
says your flight leaves San Francisco at
9:53 a.m. and arrives in New York at
6:20 6:00 p.m. the return flight leaves
New York at 11:42 p.m. and arrives in
San Francisco at 3:19 a.m. the next day
which flight is longer by how much so
let's tackle the first flight first so
we're leaving at 9:53 and arrive at 626
so remember this is 953 a.m. and this is
the trick of this problem this is San
Francisco time San Fran San Francisco
time and then you are arriving in New
York at 6:20 6:00 p.m. but now this
isn't San Francisco time this isn't
Pacific time this is now Eastern time so
this is New York time New York time and
to do this problem is something that you
would have to know is that New York is 3
hours ahead of San Francisco so this is
3 hours ahead 3 hours ahead so when it
is noon in San Francisco it is 3 p.m. in
New York when it is 1 in p.m. in San
Francisco it is 4 p.m. in New York and
so the trick to doing this type of
problem is to really just make sure
everything is in the same time zone so
either put our San Francisco time in New
York time and then we can subtract or
put the New York time in San Francisco
time and then we can subtract so let's
put everything for the sake of this
problem let's put everything in Eastern
Time so to do that we have to take our
our San Francisco Times and add 3 hours
so plus plus 3 hours and we have to be
careful here because you could say 9
plus 12 that'll get us to 12 53 but we
have to be careful here because we're no
longer at 12:53 a.m. we are now at 12:53
p.m. and you could draw a number line
why should I should say a time line here
to make that clear if you're at 9:53
a.m.
9 9:53 a.m. if you go one hour let me
draw a longer a longer a longer time
line over here if you're at 9:53 if you
add one hour you're at 10:53
these are a.m. a.m. you got another hour
you are at 11:53 1153 my handwriting is
getting messy 11 11:53 a.m. and then you
add another hour so our third hour
you're now crossing the threshold from
a.m. into p.m. so you are now at 12:53
but it is not is no longer a.m. it is
now p.m. so one way you could think
about this first flight we're leaving
San Francisco 12:53 p.m. Eastern Time
so now this is New York so this is
Eastern Time and then we are arriving in
New York at 6:20 6:00 p.m. Eastern Time
and now we can literally just subtract
this time from that time especially
because they're both p.m. that's the
easiest way to do it we could do it with
the timeline that would work as well but
just for simplicity let's take let's so
we're finishing at 6:20 6:00 p.m. we
started at 12:53 we're starting at 12:53
p.m. and now you might say wait how do
you subtract 12:53 p.m. from 626 p.m.
and the key here is to put both of them
in essentially military time this is
essentially this is if you put it in
military time this is still going to be
this is still going to be 1253 if you
put this up here in military time you
would add 12 to it and so this is going
to be 1826 1826 so I added I added
twelve here to put that into military
time and now the subtraction becomes
pretty straightforward so you have 6
minus 3 is 3 minutes you have 2 minus 5
is essentially 20 minutes minus 50
minutes and right here you're like well
how do I subtract a larger number
I'm a smaller number and we can borrow
or regroup so we will borrow one hour
from the 18 hours or from this eight
hours right over here that will become
seven hours now we have an hour to put
into this spot an hour is six ten minute
periods this is our 10-minute spot so
you would add you would add six to this
so this is how it's different than
traditional borrowing or regrouping you
would since you have an hour that's
equivalent to 60 minutes so 60 minutes
plus 20 minutes is 80 minutes it looks
like we took a 6 and added to two but
that's because we're doing it in the 10
minute spot the 10 minute place we
really took 60 minutes from out of here
and added to this 20 minutes and got 80
minutes but what that allows us to do is
now subtract 80 minutes minus 50 minutes
is 30 minutes and then you have seven
hours minus two hours is five hours and
then one and then you have ten hours
minus 10 hours or and the ones cancel
out and we're left with five hours and
33 minutes five hours and 33 minutes
five hours and 33 minutes is how long
our first flight takes now let's try to
tackle the second flight the second
flight is interesting because we're
leaving at 11:42 p.m. and arriving in
San Francisco at 319 a.m. the next day
so once again let's convert everything
to Eastern Time so we're leaving at
11:00 11:42
p.m. and then we are arriving that's
Eastern Time and then we're arriving at
319 a.m. Pacific time if we want to
convert that 319 to Eastern you add
three hours so this is six to six 19
a.m. and there's two ways that you can
do this actually more than two ways the
simplest way might just be with a number
line especially because you're crossing
this day we're crossing 12 a.m. going
into the next day so if we think about
it that way so that's my time line if
we're starting at 11:42 p.m. it'll take
us 18 minutes to get to midnight so
that's 18 minutes to midnight gets us to
12 a.m. and then we get another 6 hours
and 19
minutes and then we have another six
hours six hours and 19 minutes to get to
when our flight lands in San Francisco
remember and this is all in Eastern time
so this is 619 a.m. Eastern time
although we're landing in San Francisco
so we can literally just add these up so
it's going to be six hours six hours and
then 19 plus 18 is 37 minutes 6 hours
and 37 minutes so clearly going from San
Francisco to New York took less time
than coming back we probably have a
headwind of some type coming back now
the other way we could have done it and
this is a little less intuitive because
we're not we're going to use some type
of time frame that isn't so obvious
you could have subtracted 1114 1142 from
619 and you could have done it by doing
something a little bit strange you could
have said that so we're going to
subtract 1140 - let me do it so you're
going to subtract 1140 - and you were to
subtract it from 619 but 619 it's in the
next time period so I want to do this it
won't be military time because in
military time you would just say it's
619 a.m. but we're saying since we're
subtracting from it something in the
previous time period in the previous 12
hour period I'm still going to add 12
hours to it because then work if we
didn't reset it to it I guess we should
say 1 a.m. if we didn't go from 12 to 1
and we just kept going so it became 13
1,300 hours or I shouldn't say that
because that's military time and then 14
and 15 this eventually would get to 18
instead of 6 19 a.m. so this isn't
military time this is some bizarre thing
that I'm just setting up just so that
the math works out but this you could
rewrite since it's in the next time
period from the 11:40 - you could write
this as 18 18 19 and then you can
subtract so 9 minus 2 is 7 you have 1
minus 4 can't do that
borrow an hour so you get that becomes a
7 if you borrow an hour here you have 10
minutes here you're going to be able to
add 60 minutes to it so that becomes a 7
7 minus 4 is 3 and then 7 minus 1 is 6
then these cancel out so once again you
get 6 hours and
37 minutes either way the return flight
is longer